town for Chicago for turnovers for
Chicago and none for the pelicans so
that's how you take care of the
basketball
dozens gone hard and heavy he's got an
whopping six on the shot clock
they're not going to double I'll check
it myself good decision
boogie on their butt nice job and this
is where like they started isolating
like Kobe and dirt cause it's hard to
double-team it and whap it is to see
that coming
Valentine for three and a break fast
ball delivered well what's it going to
be propels on the dribble handoff charge
not even a dribble just a simple hand
top there's only 20 still grow baby gets
it
Gordon lead by cooking cookies that any
times now with finish nails three
mid-range game there is better because
it follows it up
Bogey's up tonight ten and fourteen with
nine assists rookies got it out
a be sent the pic form don't need a
three Hubbell of the Marcus dozens
they've been running this for a while
now and have great chemistry great
timing great understanding and